hi everyone
uh welcome to this afternoon session uh
my name is rohan verma i'm a vice
president at ogilvy
a global advertising communications firm
that works here in the dc area
with nins a lot and today's session is
going to be on how to use social media
to promote brain science
uh really excited to walk you through
about 30 minutes of pre-recorded content
followed by a q a with my co-presenters
daniella whitten and russ
poldrack uh we're going to get started
here in just a moment
and i hope you guys enjoy this this
evening session
okay we're just gonna dive right in um
and i'm just gonna go over
some trends uh some facts about social i
think if you were joining us this
evening
uh or this afternoon wherever you are um
you probably are already invested or
thinking about social so i'll just give
you some more reasons to
use it um and then we will quickly dive
through a few slides and
uh i will hand it off to our panelists
to talk about more of their so
their personal experience with social
media
so first question why social i think the
obvious answer is
uh no matter who you're communicating
with what you're communicating about
some portion of your audience is on
social
uh it's about 64 of the u.s population
is on some form of social media
and although we often think of social
media being a gen z
or a millennial uh platform adults over
the age of 35 actually make up the
largest segment the fastest growing
segment of users
um and a lot of quite a lot of questions
have come up lately about what social
means
in the pandemic and really how we're
using social as we're all sort of
uh physically distant but maybe more
connected in different ways and
uh this is just a quick study from a
quick uh
graph from axios to nielsen media uh
that just demonstrates that we're all
increasingly
increasingly connected by social um it's
been
even more ingrained in our daily lives
more so we haven't been zoomer face time
you can see sort of
video and productivity apps uh growing
but not quite to the pace of how social
media
has grown just over the last four months
this is sort of an indication of
the apps and the platforms we're using
most so
it's really social over anything else
okay so why is social media actually
important for research and talking about
brain science in particular
well the three different models we have
in front of us on this slide show
the theory of influence um and what
you're really looking at
is a paradigm shift in the way we
communicate particularly for science
so on the left most uh model the
influencer node
what we're really looking at is more of
a traditional model of publications or
traditional press releases
sort of determined how far information
traveled
and obviously that's not the case
anymore the second model
on the middle of the screen there is
network dispersion and what that's
really demonstrating
is what your networks really do right so
science is a social
uh as a social uh endeavor um so really
communicating with your own networks and
how far those stretches how far
information was allowed to travel in the
past and now what we've got
with social and with the more digital
platforms is a combination of the two
we're calling the node plus network
model where the
free flow of information and and ideas
uh isn't inhibited by how far your own
personal networks stretch
but really how far a combination of
those two things the the influencer node
and the network dispersion model
can really get us
so what can i do on social as as a
researcher as a scientist like as an
academic you're probably asking a lot of
this
a lot of these questions to yourself
when you think about social
how do i get started what can i really
do so this is just a poll of about a
thousand
research professionals and academics
i think this was in nature last year and
it just talks about the different
reasons that
folks are using social and really
they're doing any number of things you
can see a lot of different activity here
but the most common uses are to follow
discussions
discover and contact peers and post more
of their own work
and the more of these users you can
really tap into the more powerful social
can be for you
it's easier now more than ever to share
your work directly with your audiences
so what should i post again another
study in nature
i think this is again 2019 is just
looking at what
different academics what different
researchers what different
folks are doing across their social
platforms
and again science and research are
social endeavors so
what does that mean well really gives us
an opportunity to connect with peers
not only read their research connect
with them and ask them questions
directly about those things but share
your own as well
so there's a lot of bibliometrics that
prove this out but there's a strong
positive correlation between traditional
measures of academic success
the number of citations the number of
secondary citations and social media
engagement
um i'm sure you guys have all sort of uh
seen the lag between a paper being
released and the accumulation of
citations for that study or to that
paper and what social media does is
really fill that gap
so what you're seeing is the gap the
year or two gap that can exist between
a study being released and it began
beginning to get cited
or referenced in other words is filled
by the conversation
that can happen on social and i know
some of our panelists today probably
have a lot of experience with that
and i'm sure many of you do as well
so let's dive into the channels a little
bit um we're
probably going to spend more time
talking about twitter than anything else
i think twitter is probably the
strongest and most useful channel for
uh for research and for academia
it is often seen as the place where
content conversation starts uh and
discussion flourishes
um and i know our presentations later
we'll talk more about that
um but there are a few other channels
that you might find useful as you
consider how to get started on social as
you consider what you want to actually
post
um you want to think about your audience
of course uh if you want to reach more
of that research conversation if you
want to have more of those conversations
with your peers
uh twitter is a great place linkedin is
also a great place to start
uh it is considered the professional
social network and you might
might find peers and organizations
groups on linkedin that you may not find
on twitter as easily
the the one thing to note here is two of
these sites that are on the screen
actually comprise two of the four most
visited sites
in the world um you can guess what the
first one is google outranks everything
else
but not too far behind that is actually
youtube and then coming in
fourth is facebook so those two
platforms between video and longer form
content
and community building that you might be
able to accomplish on facebook
there's a there's a lot of value there
facebook is going to likely be a
community building tool that you want to
use
more of a consumer or lay audience than
you do with your scientific or academic
peers
but i think it still has a lot of value
depending on what you want to do with
your research and where you want it to
be
uh who you want to read it and where you
want to get it um
and so to piggyback on that i think
instagram as a visual storytelling
platform is super powerful too
we've used this at ovule with a lot of
our clients in the in the academia
science space
i know we've talked about it with a lot
of the nih ics as well so
something to consider especially you're
more of a visual storyteller yourself
obviously shorter form content but can
really stand out in the feed and capture
more attention if you have visuals to
accompany your content
and then finally really what is the
discussion all about is
where do i start so if you joined us
last year or perhaps
have already kind of invested a little
bit in social i'm sure a lot of these
things come up for you
uh just a little quip here from a tom
gold comic
uh it's all great but uh you're making
discoveries saving lives and publishing
great research but uh
you know maybe the question you're
getting from your your press peers and
uh folks in the media departments at
your universities and institutions
is well your your research isn't making
an impact on social
uh obviously just tongue and cheek there
that is not the important thing in
research
uh but it is important when you're
thinking about how to develop a
following and how to
engage on social try to be consistent uh
try to develop a following and nurture
that readership
uh leverage the easy stuff repost your
colleagues work repost things from
from press publications or industry
publications that you follow
and above all really look at what works
uh and be social be social you know we
talked a couple times now in the last
few minutes here about
why science is a social endeavor and i
think
more than anywhere else social media
offers you the opportunity to do that
without a lot of time investing
um just commenting liking uh telling
someone
that you really enjoyed uh their article
or pointing out
uh you know what what uh what what the
community the research community as a
whole might do to take that study or
paper further
um i think are all great things that are
pretty low effort
for some of you to just jump in five
minutes between uh
between uh commuting home or and maybe
uh in these these these uh strange times
that we all live in it's the
10 minutes of peace you get before your
morning coffee um
really easy chances to jump in on social
and engage
uh but we'll hear more about that from
our panelists in just a few moments
i'm actually going to hand it off now to
one of our other panelists
daniella whitten is going to talk about
her own use in social and particularly
twitter
all right thank you so much for the
intro rohan so i'm excited to uh tell
you guys today a little bit about why i
use twitter
and to begin this is my twitter profile
um it has sort of the basics about me
and and why someone might be interested
in the things that i have to say
i wanted to start by pointing out that i
joined
twitter pretty late so i joined less
than three years ago
and um of course twitter has been around
for
for over 10 years and there's a lot of
academics on twitter who've been there
since 2009 or 2010
and so i'm very late to the game and i'm
also a pretty minor player
so if you get used to using twitter
you'll know that a lot of
professors and post-docs and grad
students have twenty thousand fifty
thousand
almost a hundred thousand followers and
um
i really have a very narrow slice of the
twitter community that i interact with
so um um so please keep that in mind
when you hear me talk i'm i'm both new
to it and i'm a minor player
but i have found that twitter has come
with a lot of benefits for me
and in order to be able to talk to you
guys today um
yesterday i launched a poll asking my
colleagues on twitter uh what is their
primary reason for using twitter
and i was surprised to see really an
interesting set of reasons
um i thought that a lot of people would
answer that they're using twitter to
disseminate their research
um but no people are mostly using it to
keep up with their research and to
network in the field
along with um a number of replies that i
got in the comments
um indicating uh sort of one-off reasons
that people might feel a benefit to
using twitter professionally
i also ask people what is the most major
impact that twitter has had on their
scientific career
and not surprisingly a lot of people use
twitter as the basis for starting a
collaboration
with another researcher um but a fair
number of people actually found that
twitter was a way to get a job i think
but in particular
if you are thinking about where to go
for grad school or deciding
which postdoc lab to join then twitter
could be a really great way to get to
know the department or the
pi virtually before you go there in
person
and a number of people found that
twitter was a way to actually get in a
real life invitation so irl means
in real life and um surprisingly that is
is a source of invitations for a lot of
people
um so what do i use twitter for well i
already have a job so i'm not using it
to get a job
um but i do use it for things that for
me are pretty high
value and so one reason that i use
twitter is as a way to read high quality
peer review
that's really hot off the presses so of
course right now in the middle of the
covet 19 crisis
a lot of what i'm following on twitter
has to do with that crisis
um and twitter is a great way to really
find out
for example the scientific opinion of
the leading experts on
some of the many many pre-prints that
are coming out every day about coded 19
and if you follow people who are putting
these really high quality peer reviews
out there
it's actually staggering how quickly you
can get information
that that would take weeks or months to
come out in more traditional channels
and i also really enjoy twitter as a way
to get exposure to scientific topics
outside of my immediate field
so i'm a statistician i'm certainly not
a virologist but it's been really fun to
follow people who know more about topics
that i don't know about
in order to learn what's happening um
especially as it relates to current
events
so on the again the set of people out
there today who are posting really
relevant information about
kobit 19 is just incredible and
staggering and it's so
great to through twitter sort of be in
the front seat of the scientific
dialogue
the front rather i should say the front
seat of the audience of the scientific
dialogue
um but outside of the current crisis um
one thing that i really enjoyed about
being on twitter is that it allows me to
keep up with best practices
so often i'll see on twitter a dialogue
that's emerging among grad students and
postdocs and pis
which sort of bubbles up through twitter
over time and then eventually it makes
it into the mainstream news
and into university policy but often it
will have been discussed on twitter for
six months or even a year or two
before it bubbles up so here's one
example um
within the past year a lot of
universities
have started prohibiting graduate
students from catering their own
dissertation defenses and of course the
reason to prohibit grad students from
catering their own dissertation defenses
is because
grad students should be busy preparing
for their dissertations
and shouldn't be expected to spend time
baking cakes or going to the grocery
store
and furthermore that's putting a
financial burden on grad students
so there's a lot of good reasons on that
that various universities are preventing
grad students from catering their own
defenses
but before it started to become
university policy at a lot of places
this was really an ongoing discussion on
twitter so i like to be able to hear
about these things really before they
happen
another similar example of this has to
do with the idea that in the last few
years
people have really questioned the value
of the gre
for graduate school admissions to many
stem phd programs
and so um increasingly graduate programs
are dropping the gre as
an application requirement and this is
something that i heard about
a long time ago on twitter um before it
was showing up in science and being
removed from the set of requirements for
graduate programs
on a large scale like it is today
so another thing that i really benefit
from by using twitter is just the
opportunity to be the member
a member of a supportive community
and so um of course graduate school can
be very alienating for a lot of our phd
students
um it's a hard academic road being
junior faculty is tough
and it's really nice to see like a
really warm side
of an academic community where it's very
easy for an individual to feel alienated
but it can really help that individual
to see that they're not alone and that
other people share some of their
struggles
so by being part of this community it
both helps me feel supported
but also it gives me tools to support my
trainees as they might
experience hardships in their graduate
careers or during their postdocs
so especially right now um when we are
in the midst of a pandemic
and certainly all the conferences in my
field have gone virtual for the year
um twitter can be a really good way to
keep in touch because a lot of those
sort of casual conversations that you
have
during a conference in between sessions
at the mixer
at the end of the day at that conference
a lot of those conversations are
actually happening
on twitter and so if you are feeling
isolated
in this current environment then twitter
is just a really great way to feel less
isolated and to
really keep up with your call with what
your colleagues are doing
in the same way that you would if you
went to that conference
and so obviously during this current
crisis this is an especially good time
to do some of that networking online
but many of us um have reasons to avoid
excessive travel even when there's not a
pandemic so here's a photo of my three
kids
i try to only travel to conferences that
are really critical for me
professionally
and by being somewhat active on twitter
that gives me a chance to
catch up on some of what i miss by not
going to more conferences in person
so i just want to close by saying um
that these are some of the reasons that
i use twitter i should mention that i
use it very casually
um i often go for weeks without looking
at my twitter and then sometimes i use
it more
um and so you might want to try it out
but if you do try it out i would suggest
that you keep it fun have a sense of
humor about it
don't think of this as very important
career development or networking because
i don't think it is
or at least for me it's not um it could
be more of a fun way to keep up with
your colleagues and to relieve a little
bit of stress and to feel more supported
in this career all right um that is it
for me
and i'm going to turn it over to russ
now
all right well thanks very much for the
invitation um happy to be here and talk
about how i
use social media uh to try to you know
advance neuroscience so
just to say a bit about kind of my
social media history i actually um i
think my first social media account was
actually on my space in the mid 2000s
which some of you may remember
uh is it was a big music site um but
doesn't really exist anymore um i
started using facebook
around 2007 um and
for a long time that was like a you know
a way that i would sort of communicate
with a lot of my
fellow neuroscientists but i joined to
twitter in 2009 and
for at least the last five years twitter
has been kind of the main platform that
i use for
social media engagement um i i like the
the openness of it and um and i find the
community there to be you know really
supportive
and uh and productive so i want to say a
bit about kind of how i use
social media um first kind of you know
what's my mo and i would call it a low
volume
memo you know really trying to like not
tweet that much and aiming for a
relatively high signal noise ratio so
this is my tweet volume over the last
year per
month and you can see on average i uh
tweet about a hundred tweets a month so
you know a few a day
except for uh march 2020 when i had a
little kovid 19 freak out and was
tweeting a little bit more
um but i'm kind of back down to my
normal levels now
so what do i tweet about um i would say
you know the first thing that i probably
tweet the most about is my group's work
um you know whenever we have a new paper
uh this is an example of a new preprint
we just put out a couple weeks ago
and i find it's a way to kind of you
know get our work
in front of people's eyes we've
certainly you know when we've submitted
preprints and and i've tweeted about
them they've ended up a number of them
have ended up getting you know pretty
good altmetrics uh engagement
um and so so i think it's been really
useful to kind of you know funnel people
towards the work that we're doing
um i also like to uh tweet about
you know things that i've done wrong my
own errors this is one that i tweeted a
couple weeks ago about having
made a stupid mistake in doing
simulations and i think it's important
for
for senior people to kind of you know
model uh
owning our errors and owning the fact
that we all make errors and so you know
when junior people are watching they
kind of realize that you know senior
people are just like them
um so and i try to have a sense of humor
about it when i can
um i tweet about you know papers and
books that i like
um sometimes papers in my research field
you know whenever i
see an interesting new paper i'll tweet
about that i also um
will tweet about you know things that
i've read so this is one about a book
uh by vinay prasad on cancer that i've
read recently that was
really interesting that i liked um
in terms of you know topics uh beyond
neuroscience i often also tweet about
kind of statistical and methodological
topics this is one that got a good bit
of engagement
a couple weeks ago about uh collider
bias
um and um and i find that there's a you
know there's an interesting kind of
parallel community on twitter of people
who really care about statistics and
methodology
um and i try to kind of straddle those
communities
and then finally um i tweet a lot in the
context of sort of
open science advocacy um you know often
either kind of highlighting you know new
projects
new tools new efforts that i think are
you know kind of pushing
in the right direction occasionally you
know being critical but
uh but trying in general to you know
sort of highlight the good
rather than sort of accentuate the bad
now you know it's easy to kind of drive
yourself crazy on twitter if you
if you watch the the kind of the main
twitter feed and especially if you have
any degree of
fear of missing out it's really easy to
just become completely overloaded and
feel like you have to spend every moment
of every
day watching the twitter feed so um
so i've tried to avoid that with what i
kind of jokingly call my narcissistic
twitter strategy which is
i mostly watch my notifications page and
so if somebody mentions me
or you know sometimes it'll forward
something if somebody who i follow
or follower of mine has kind of tweeted
something you know that's
that's gotten a lot of attention it'll
pop up on my notifications so it's a
for me it's a much higher snr way to see
what's going on
uh really reduces the amount of noise
that one sees obviously you know you
miss out on a lot of stuff but for me
um i try not to let the the fomo kind of
you know drive me crazy
okay so what are my rules um the first
rule i would say is
try as hard as i can to keep it positive
um i try generally to
you know not be hypercritical um i've
you know
obviously we all we all break our rules
on occasion but but i try to really kind
of accentuate the things that i like
rather than sort of trashing on the
things that i don't like um
and a corollary to this is walk away
basically if somebody you know obviously
you can tweet positive things and
there's always going to be people who
are going to try to kind of you know
trash on them
um and you know i like to engage with
people in a
in a in as kind of you know
non-emotional way as i can
but you know if somebody's sort of you
know just kind of being
um hypercritical in a way that that um i
don't feel as productive
i just kind of say hey you know i'm i'm
walking away from this and i'm not
bashful about doing that i don't have
time to get into you know huge arguments
with people that i don't feel are
productive
i focus on science mostly occasionally
i'll post something about
you know food or something cool that my
wife has done but
for the most part i try to focus on
science in part because i feel like you
know i
going back to the the kind of you know
the highest in our goal
um you know there are a lot of people
who post a lot on twitter and they post
social stuff or they post political
stuff and i feel like i end up tuning
out of those because they're so you know
so little what they're posting about is
stuff that i really want to know about
so i try to keep it really focused on
the things that i'm pretty sure you know
most of my followers are
people in neuroscience um or data
science and i feel like i want to kind
of keep the material
largely focused on those sort of topics
um
another one is um think twice before you
say something and i
i usually am able to pull this off and
it's really kind of a check yourself
before you wreck yourself kind of idea
um and you know many for me you know as
a senior person
uh coming from where i come from you
know obviously there's a lot of
privilege that i
bring to this uh to you know to what i
do
and um and i i think it's important for
those of us in that position to really
kind of you know think about our
privilege and make sure that we're not
kind of
you know saying things that somebody
from a different background
would find defensive or or that would
you know that would kind of be little
you know somebody else's experience um
and you know we've all seen experience
we've all seen examples of you know this
going wrong
um and um and i think that you know it's
important to really kind of you know
think before you tweet
um finally don't be a bulldog by a
bulldog i mean
sort of somebody who gets into fights
and just won't let go um you know kind
of grabs on and just sort of tries to
tear something apart and that's
this is kind of a corollary to my walk
away rule um
but you know we all as scientists like
to get into arguments and confined
ourselves you know kind of
um uh digging in really deeply and i
think that you know if you're doing that
in a room with a person
there's social cues where you can kind
of you know keep it fun and
and interesting even when you are kind
of arguing uh
really intensely it's harder for those
cues to come through on social media so
i think it's really important to
kind of you know realize when you're
getting pulled into this kind of like
hyper aggressive
you know argumentation that scientists
do all the time and you know kind of
step back from that
so if you're an early career researcher
why should you be active on twitter i
think one of the most important reasons
is that
senior people like me can come to know
who you are so these are just a few
examples of you know early career
researchers
grad students you know post-docs early
early career
faculty um who i've met on twitter or
you know who i met in real life and now
follow on twitter and have gotten to
know much better
and i think it's really important you
know one when you know when i go to a
conference it's really hard for senior
people to remain engaged with junior
researchers
from across the field and so when i go
to conferences now
i see these people and i you know know
them feel like i know them well can have
conversations with them and i think it's
good for both of us
so what about uh senior people why
should we do it well
one reason is that it can actually pay
off and this is my favorite example it's
a tweet that i
uh posted a number of years ago
about a talk that a member of my group
had given and got a response from
somebody
from a foundation stuart buck he said
interested in chatting sometime
this is a keen interest in my foundation
this is the arnold foundation
so i was like sure yeah let's do it um
we ended up talking to him
fast forward to the following year we
get a four million dollar grant
um from the foundation to you know to
move forward some of the work that we're
doing
so um so this is a way in which you know
it can literally
pay off in addition to all the other
payoffs um
so so uh thanks very much for the
opportunity again to speak
hopefully i will see you all online and
i'm at russ poldrack at twitter
and now let's move into uh opening up to
live questions
thank you
thanks everyone i think just as a
reminder
you can submit your questions uh in the
bottom here
uh and we will be fielding them as they
come in um
russ i'd actually like to start with
something that you just sort of
mentioned at the end of that
presentation which was
how you deal with trolls and maybe
negative comments on social media
yeah this is uh this is always uh
challenging
um and you know like i said part of it
is that i try to i try to be as
matter-of-fact as possible and not you
know so it's really hard to
not read emotion into uh online content
but i try to do my best not to read
emotion into it
um and uh so that's that's part of it
um you know i've had one person who i've
had to block
um and they actually went and got
another twitter handle which i had to
block unfortunately
that's the only kind of real troll i've
had to deal with
um and i feel like you know not i think
there's a trick to not letting things
escalate when you're having a just
obviously some people are just you know
going to be trolls and kind of
there's nothing you can do about it i
think then you just have to block them
but i think just trying not to escalate
uh you know and sort of going back to
the bulldog comment that i made
trying to kind of keep things as kind of
matter of fact as possible as has
worked for me at least
yeah that's great danielle anything to
add from your own experience
sorry about that i guess you couldn't
hear me uh let me try that again
yeah i've been fortunate not to um
experience much trolling on twitter i
know that many people have experienced a
lot of trolling
but luckily i've only experienced a
little bit and when i have i've been
able to
kind of have a thick skin on it about it
and at the risk of maybe making a joke
about something that's not funny
um which one should never do uh
as a woman in science you have to have a
pretty thick skin and so i've been
fortunate that nothing i've seen on
twitter
has been worse than things that i see
all the time every day in real life as a
woman in science
for better or worse but i do realize
that many people do
get much worse treatment on twitter than
than i do
it's sort of a related question our
thoughts on
anonymous handles inside in the science
domain so
you know a lot of anonymous handles both
on twitter and uh you sometimes see
these on facebook as well
commenting on uh recent publications
recent articles um i'll start with you
again last any thoughts
on sort of this anonymity in the social
space
um i you know i think it can be useful
for some people some of the time i know
there are
you know there are people who have you
know sometimes really good
ideas who are nonetheless sort of um you
know for various reasons
not comfortable putting it out there
under their own name especially if
they're being critical of you know
powerful people who might be able to
retaliate against them and then you know
in the space that i follow there's a few
of you know a few anonymous people who i
i
pay attention to um certainly the bar is
higher for me to pay attention to an
anonymous handle
but but i think it can be a useful
feature for
for some people
yeah it's really interesting i think um
sorry go ahead danielle
anonymous candles and i mean for one
thing like there's a lot of people who
use their name on twitter but i don't
know them personally and maybe if i did
a google search i might not be able to
find them because they might be a grad
student or a postdoc who doesn't have an
academic website
and so as far as i'm concerned most
people who i see on twitter are
anonymous you know like
faculty whose names i know are the best
exception
and um i don't really see that as an
issue i very rarely see people who i
interact with
who are using anonymity as a way to
close bad behavior
um and much more often it's someone who
is either effectively an honest to me
just because i don't know who they are
or haven't given their name but that
doesn't really have any bearing in
whether or not they have useful things
to say
yeah it's interesting i think um to
build on that um
maybe you could answer this question are
there ways that you
kind of identified influencers or
collaborators and kind of valued the
relationships you've built on social
i think russ you mentioned an example of
a funder uh at the end of your
presentation
um i'm wondering what uh maybe checklist
you might run through and thinking about
how you value the authority or or
or sort of uh
i don't know the word i'm looking for
here is but maybe just the how you how
you value a relationship you've built on
social how you identify people that are
trustworthy and reliable
um i can't say i've been very strategic
about it at all i cut you know things
grow organically
and um and i kind of follow them where
they lead
i'd say one thing that's fun about um
getting to know people a little bit
better on twitter
is that it allows you to find out what
people you might not know very well
really care about so like you know i'll
follow person x on twitter and then when
i go give a talk at their university
it's just like a fun thing immediately
to be able to connect on things that i
know that that person cares about
because i've seen them posting a ton
about like
open source software and so i know
straight off the bat that that's going
to be like a conversation topic that
we're going to have a shared interest in
rather than sort of like puttering
around and trying to find
the the intersection of the things that
we care about
i mean i would also sorry i would add
that um
you know one thing that's been really
useful for me is you know often i want
to get feedback on
like something i've written or some
particular question that i have
that's outside of my expertise and kind
of you know knowing people on twitter's
been really useful for that to be able
to message them and say
hey you know i have this question about
this particular brain thing that you're
expert in and i'm not can you can you
help me with that
uh and i'll pose this both to both it
has been easy to find collaborators
both on your research and to collaborate
with others on their research
through social
i i haven't found um collaborators
through social media and i wouldn't say
that that has been a goal of mine
but it has been pretty easy to find like
the community that i'm interested in
which for me is like
you know statistics meets computational
biology meets some neuroscience
with a um also like a smattering of
social justice as it relates to academia
in particular
so like the people who are interested in
those things i tend to be interested in
what they have to say
i tend to follow them and i tend to be
pretty aware of who some of those key
players are
on twitter because they always have
really interesting things to talk about
one thing i want to mention by the way
this is a little bit off topic but um
you know this this
recording that got played at the
beginning of this session was recorded a
couple of weeks ago
and um in that session i mentioned sort
of a number of ways that
being on twitter can be really useful in
terms of just like being aware of like
what are some of the
big social conversations happening
in academia and i gave a couple of
examples about like you know the gre
and how to support postdocs and grad
students and i just want to mention that
was recorded a couple weeks ago like
what's happening on twitter and what's
the big focus obviously changes over
time so if you've been on twitter in the
last week
um or even if you haven't been on
twitter you won't be surprised to know
that right now um issues having to do
with systemic racism and police
brutality
are very much what people and like the
academic twitter circles are discussing
right now
in terms of how we can work to try to
fix these problems support our trainees
support our fellow faculty at this very
challenging time
and i just want to mention to anyone out
in the audience it's not that i was
emitting this uh it was we recorded this
two weeks ago and that was
two weeks ago of course not as much in
the forefront as it is today and during
this past week
yeah we didn't all just do uh wardrobe
changes mid presentation
so you know i like daniella i also
haven't really found
kind of scientific collaborators on
twitter i have ended up you know being
co-author on a number of papers
that or at least a couple of papers that
sort of grew out of social media
discussions that were more like sort of
review
things or you know sort of um uh
one of them actually was a they've
they've all you know been
in in interaction with more early career
people one of them was explicitly about
like you know how to
how to like build your career um
particularly if you want to do open
science
um that that i was lucky enough to to be
an author on it came out of neuron a few
weeks ago
so for me that's been the real
opportunity is kind of getting involved
in writing
projects that i might not have gotten
involved in were enough for social media
uh that's great no i think there's a
couple questions about whether we'll be
sharing our slides i believe
uh the recording of this session will be
up for a while and i think we'll
also be sending out a one pager that'll
be available
uh through names um that contains some
of the highlights from
this afternoon session
there's a question here about finding
research opportunities i think sort of
uh
answered uh in light by by some of the
most recent institutions given but
um have you found i found it useful to
find resources or other
links to other things in the music
social
go ahead danielle
um i i guess my social media use really
has been limited
especially in a professional context has
been limited to twitter
um and so there isn't really much
outside of that that i have
have been involved in in particular in a
professional testing i guess i've used
um
i have a linkedin account um i can't say
that it's
something that i look at more than you
know maybe once every two years probably
um or that i give much stuff to
yeah i mean for me one of the probably
the most useful things is i just
learning about um
projects particularly like software
projects that i didn't know about like i
found a lot of people in the python
kind of scientific python space and you
know i'm always learning about some cool
new thing that somebody
has done and you know often it's been
something that actually feeds into
either teaching or research for me so
that's been really useful
um sort of related uh there's a question
here about
other social media platforms so danielle
you mentioned you're mostly on twitter
you do use linkedin occasionally um in
my presentation we also
mentioned just the use of a couple of
academia and research specific platforms
uh researchgate academy.edu i don't know
if uh
you've had experience with either of
those i don't know if you can speak to
that first danielle and then
russ uh for you maybe more specifically
since you seem to have a longer history
with some of these other platforms
uh if there are other platforms you've
come across both in your
past use uh and then currently that you
might be using
yeah i have not i don't think i've ever
used academia.edu
i think i maybe once
looked at researchgate because they send
a lot of emails
um but i you know in all honesty i have
not found those to be useful for me and
i i can definitely see that that might
differ depending on your subfield but
for me as a statistician um
you know like i think that maybe one of
the appeals of researchgate is that it
might make it
easier to get access to um journal
articles that are behind a paywall
i think that is a possible use case for
researchgate but as a statistician you
know the papers that i want to read
if there is if there is a paywall that i
can't get through um they're typically
posted on archive which is like this
the math stat version of bio archive
and so i just haven't had much of a use
for for any of those alternative sites
but i'm sure that does vary by subfield
yeah i also in general have avoided
those other like researchgate
academy.edu
um sorts of things um you know i used
like i said i used to do a lot more on
facebook and actually one of the
interesting things that happened that
kind of
really got me to stop having these sort
of discussions on facebook
i i kind of trashed on a paper
pretty hard um in a way that i
was not uh becoming and the
the comments even though the person who
i was trashing on wasn't a friend of
mine and the advisor of the person who i
was trashing on wasn't a friend of mine
the comments actually somebody forwarded
them to
this like grad student who had written
this paper that i was trashing on and
they felt really bad and obviously if i
hadn't like known if i had thought that
this grad student was going to see the
comments i would not have said what i
said
and so it really kind of highlighted for
me the fact that even though facebook
can kind of seem
private that nothing is really private
and so in some ways you know twitter
like
the idea that you're always that
everything is always public it's for me
is a bit of a commitment device to like
to make me consider the public impact of
anything that i say
yeah i'll build from that question that
i asked in that answer um
and ask about what what do you do when
perhaps someone in your group or a
trainee or graduate student that you're
working with
posts something about the research that
you're doing that you don't agree with
um honestly i've never had that happen
if it did happen um
i guess it depends on how egregious it
what it you know
it is uh i i probably would let it go
um or have a sidebar conversation with
them or say something you know jokingly
snarky i
i guess i did you know we had a paper
come out a couple weeks ago in nature
and one of my
the other senior co-author and i had not
really like a
not really an argument but you know he
didn't agree with something that i had
said on twitter he thought i was like
rolling over too easily on some
criticisms and we had a little back and
forth
but we we try to do it in kind of a
joking way so i
that you know i generally try to bring
humor to kind of defuse any sort of
argument so that would probably be
if i had to do that that would be my
strategy
i did god have you ever run into a
situation like that
um no i haven't um
but i guess maybe to interpret the
question a little bit differently from
how russ did i think another
interpretation of the question is what
would i do
if i saw like a you know a student or a
post-operative junior colleague
posting something on twitter that maybe
is just ill-advised for
for professional reasons or for social
reasons and i think an instance like
that for me is like a really great
opportunity to either send them an email
um
send them a direct message on twitter or
somehow just like take it offline
and just maybe give them a soft
suggestion that that what they posted
may not have had the intended effect
and that they maybe maybe the joke
wasn't as funny as they thought or or
whatever it is
um and i think like you know i
i actually mentioned that i would send a
message a private message to like a
student or a postdoc or a junior college
but actually i would send it to a senior
colleague too
um i think that we could all appreciate
people looking out for us and maybe
politely telling us behind the scenes
like hey that might have come across
wrong and maybe you want to clarify your
post
um i certainly wouldn't mind if someone
sends me a note like that
yeah you know there's a there's a
related question here that i'll post the
first to you danielle
and that is um separating personal and
professional tweets and
sort of a line between the two obviously
you both mentioned bringing your own
personality and making it fun
um to engage over social um but
the question here is should you maintain
two different accounts for two different
purposes
um and how one would just go about
managing that especially when obviously
everyone's working in a
time limited environment
so um you know i have one twitter
account and i would
characterize it as semi-professional in
the sense that like
it states it stated very clearly that
i'm a professor it stated very clearly
what i'm a professor of and what
university i work at
but i try to keep my content sort of
i don't i don't want to say
light-hearted because sometimes the
things i'm tweeting about are serious
but what i mean is it's not like
here you know here's the latest paper i
read and i'm concerned about one of the
assumptions in theorem four
instead it's more like kind of what it's
like life as a professor
like what are the challenges that i face
and and how does that relate to the
human condition
is sort of how i would characterize my
twitter account and so
it's it's not all professional um but to
the extent that it's not professional i
view it as like
things that are going to be shared by
like many of the people who i follow and
who follow me on twitter which are like
aspects of just like
the funny side of being in academia and
the irony and the humor
that you need to bring to your life um
if you're gonna you know put up with
this job
uh 24 7 for the rest of your career
um and i think that there's a place for
that on twitter
um but if i if i were someone who wanted
to like post a ton of content about like
what bands i'm really into
or like the play-by-play of like all the
recipes i made for dinner last weekend
then that wouldn't really match um
with having you know like a in my
opinion a professional semi-professional
twitter account
that for example like clearly states my
university affiliation
so i think that um in terms of whether
it's better to have one account or two i
think you need to look at like what what
type of content are you posting and
would you
hope that the content you're posting
would be of interest to people in
academia
um for the most part and then
if if instead you're sort of targeting
it at a different group like people who
are really into the particular type of
music you're into
then maybe having two twitter accounts
one of which is more academic and one of
which is more into music
could make sense potentially
yeah i totally agree with that i mean i
only have one uh twitter handle
i've thought on occasion of you know
trying to have another one but i'm not
my interest i don't have a like a really
central other interest that it would be
focused on like you know some particular
band or some particular thing i guess it
would be barbecue because i like to make
barbecue
um but uh i do occasionally tweet about
barbecue on my
my twitter account um but i you know i i
agree
i mostly i don't really use social media
for
more personal stuff other than like you
know people who message me on facebook i
just don't
feel the need for that in my life i
really kind of get everything i need out
of twitter and then out of
well before the last three months out of
irl interactions those have gone to
public
yeah i think um just in professionally
the advice i'd offer to
others um is also just picking the
channel
right so russ mentioned that he used
facebook for a specific purpose and
twitter for another purpose so i think
that's another
easy way to segment your different parts
of your life without
having to create a second twitter handle
or do things like that and i think
uh it's going to ultimately depend on be
dependent on how you want to present
your
personal brand so to speak to your
colleagues
um a good question came in that i think
russell sort of touched on but
i'm going to open it to both of you and
maybe unless leslie can answer first
um it's uh the question here is what do
senior pis feel about potential grad
schemes
messaging them on twitter even if the
senior pi's don't follow
um i guess it depends on what they're
messaging about i mean in general
um you know if they
if they just have a question they want
to ask me you know a research question
or whatever i'm kind of fine with that
um i don't you know i don't really feel
too strongly
um you know i don't i don't usually have
the time to actually have like you know
somebody
occasionally you get a message say hey
i'd love to have a you know a
zoom chat with you about joining your
lab and it's like i get way too many of
those to actually have
zoom chats with with each of those
people but um but i don't really mind it
uh same question to you daniella uh how
do you feel about just people just
messaging messaging you when they don't
miss
not necessarily following them or engage
with them
yeah i i don't think my direct messages
are open on twitter actually
um to people who i i'm not quite sure if
it's that i need to
follow them but the point is i don't
think that someone from the general
public can actually direct message me on
twitter
and part of that is because i'm happy
for people to message me but i'm easy to
find
on google you can find my academic
website and get my email address
and i just don't have the bandwidth to
like be dealing with messages from
people on twitter and then worrying
about if i miss some
and it's just like not as well set up
for me for like long form communication
as email um so a good way to just
eliminate that is to just not have my
direct messages open
but i mean if you know if a junior
person wants to email me to
talk to me about something um i welcome
an email from them and
if it's a reason you know it's a request
that makes sense for me to
make time for it then i will and if it's
not then i'll write back just a quick
note saying i'm sorry but you know i
don't have expertise in this area or i'm
not hiring someone with that background
um and i certainly don't mind receiving
those messages
sure uh a few questions here
about just generally uh gaining
followers and followership
um and how you both started out um on
your twitter accounts
um so danielle if you wouldn't mind
answering first
your twitter account's a little bit
newer i don't know what you've found is
maybe most helpful in growing your
followers
yeah so um as i mentioned my approach to
twitter is very
casual and i haven't you know put in any
concerted effort or really any effort
into growing my followers
um i've you know i like post the things
that are of interest to me and sometimes
it's interesting to look and see
sort of where my follower account is
because i don't know exactly how
twitter's algorithm works in terms of
what
what posts it um highlights versus
getting buried in the bottom of the feed
but you know sometimes i'll post
something and it just seems like any
other thing i posted and suddenly it'll
have like 2 000
likes um and then other times i'll post
something that
i think is like equivalently interesting
and and like you know it'll get like one
like
um so i think i don't know exactly how
that plays into like look versus you
know the
the nuances of twitter's algorithm or
whatever
um but regardless um
i would say if you're trying to grow
your following um
obviously the more content you put out
that is going to
elicit the um greatest interaction from
your
your followers but then also just from
the twitter community at a whole as a
whole is going to grow your
following as much as possible but that
being said
um i haven't i haven't actively tried to
grow my twitter following again because
like i don't
you know i don't need this this is just
like a fun semi-professional release
it's a nice way to find out what's
happening out there
both in terms of the scientific and the
non-scientific side of academia
and again i suggest just like keeping it
fun and
you know don't worry about it it would
be pretty hard to keep up with the
joneses because there's so many people
in academia with like fifty thousand
followers russ you're probably one of
them
so no i only have like i'm not gonna
play that game
okay well there you go that's pretty
good
um yeah i mean i also haven't really
gone out of my way to try to you know
worry about
uh followers i actually follow i think i
i you know i have like 20 something
thousand
followers and i follow maybe 400
500 people so i'm not somebody who like
goes out and tries to follow
others um i mean in terms of like what a
junior
part what an early career person can do
to try to like increase their following
obviously you know if you're a senior
person
you come on twitter you you know you if
people know you they're gonna follow you
and you know it's easier to get a
following if you're an early career
person
you know i think that the for me the
like the
the early career people i follow are one
you know people who say interesting
things
you know people who comment on stuff
that i write or
stuff that you know people who i who are
in my circle write
and who i and you know and actually have
something interesting to say and then
are you know people who like the thing
that that i would make me not want to
follow you is like being annoying like
you know being that bulldog or
like you know um like commenting in ways
that are
that are not like helpful so i think
like being you know productively
you can be productively critical i think
that's you know that's really good
um and but i think saying interesting
things you know
posting interesting posts uh you know
especially responses to people who are
who have more followers so that they'll
show up on more people's desks
i think that's probably you know in
terms of a strategy that for me that
seems like a good one
yeah i'll just add uh to recap two of
the things that you both have said
uh through the course of your
presentations one is to be social and
engage with others and your colleagues
and peers whether that's commenting on
things or whether that's
following back or you know whatever that
looks like for you um
but the other thing that i thought was
interesting and uh
uh something that was on the very last
slide of your presentation even was just
making sure that you know that others
know you're on social whether you're
interacting with them in a setting like
this where you're presenting or whether
that's uh
you know you actually maybe are at a
conference and making sure that you
follow each other there that's a
really simple step that i think a lot of
us forget about when we think about
social as compared to our
our real lives
uh let's see there's a few more
questions here i'll pick i think we have
about five minutes left so i'll pick out
a couple
um one of the questions that i think is
really uh
thought-provoking is um thinking about
uh strategies or pitfalls that you've
had uh in
in just kind of what you navigate and
post you want to
post about on twitter uh russ you
mentioned an example
uh earlier on that i think uh you get
some
a negative interaction that you'd uh
maybe not not like to repeat
uh maybe i'll start that question with
you about some common pitfalls or
challenges
you've experienced um
i think you know for me you know it's
the the main time when i've gotten in
trouble i think is is simply
just like not realizing how others might
interpret what i
say you know and unfortunately it's
never and it goes
in part this goes back to the comments i
made in my talk about you know the
privilege that i bring to this and
they're you know it's like
we all have blind spots i have
particular blind spots and sometimes
it's you know it would be easy for one
to say something
and not realize that what you're saying
is you know harmful
um and i think i've been fortunate not
to ever like screw that up
too badly but but i that goes back to my
kind of rule about you know trying to
reread things before i type them and
that doesn't always work but
um you know for me that's the big
challenge it's just kind of like
thinking about how other people might
interpret something i say and might read
it in a
in a different way and that could be a
different scientific way or it could be
you know something
more kind of social
uh and then danielle a related question
for you are there
uh especially since you mentioned you
know you kind of use
it's an extra thing for you twitter is
not something that you necessarily
build into your everyday time um are
there
strategies or tactics you use to kind of
make sure that you're getting the
content you want out of a twitter or
social environment
uh rather than things that you just
don't care about
yeah i mean i think i think as russ
alluded to
you know you just as if you want to get
followers you need to post interesting
things
well if you want me to follow you um
post things that are interesting and
often i'll like read a post
i'll be like oh like who who wrote this
i'll look at their profile and i'll see
that like the last
six things they tweeted looks pretty
interesting and then i'll follow them
and then later on if in my feed i see
that someone comes up as posting stuff
that i'm really not interested in then
i'll just unfollow
so it's like a um it's a constant
process
of just like updating who i'm following
in order to get content i'm interested
in
so for example right now i'm following
like a ton of epidemiologists
um i imagine that you can guess why and
i love epidemiologists and i certainly
was following a few of them before
february but not nearly as many as i'm
following right now
awesome uh well we just have a couple of
minutes left i don't know if either of
you have closing thoughts from sort of
the conversation we've had this
afternoon
um i will start with you daniella
yeah well i mean it was certainly really
fun for me to get to be a part of this
channel in particular i feel like i have
a lot
a lot to learn from your use of social
media i really liked hearing how you
articulated
um very clearly sort of what your
guiding principles are
um and it's yeah it's fun i guess just
to get the chance to like
talk more formally about something that
i've only ever done like very much as a
um
very very side hobby um
but i guess with the people out there
thinking about getting started i think
there can be sort of this
concern that like if you create a
twitter account if you don't have enough
followers and that'll be really
embarrassing and like you can't do it
unless you're going to have at least as
many numbers and
you got to accomplish all of your
professional goals and i would just say
like
you know try to step back from that line
of thinking
think see if this can be just like a fun
thing that you like add to your
scientific experience that helps sort of
round you out
as a scientist and a person um and
brings you some
joy or relief and if it does then great
and if it doesn't then i
i don't think you're gonna be missing
out on anything that
that you that you won't be able to make
up for in other in other ways in your
life
yeah i think that's uh i think that you
know kind of making sure that it
actually does something good for your
life is
is exactly the you know the way to think
about it
um and so yeah it's been really fun for
me to you know to kind of
think through some of these issues and
and discuss it so uh thanks for making
me part of this
excellent thank you both so much i
really enjoyed our conversation this
afternoon
hope everyone else did as well um and
thanks to
names for help setting this up and uh
hope you all enjoy the rest of uh
the meeting i don't know how many
sessions are left here but i'm sure it's
been an eventful two days
thanks thank you